"Do you have any idea how insulting that is?
I make my own decisions. For my own reasons."
"You got to listen to me, the man needs help."
"Howard, I know jimmy and you're wrong." hey guys,
Pete here. Can you believe it's been two years
since the Better Call Saul Season five finale?
No one can blame you for being a little fuzzy
on the details at this point and I'm making this
video after re-watching the entire series just
in case you didn't have time to do the same.
Since this is a prequel and a sequel we know how
things end for a lot of the main characters, but
considering there's still about four years between
the last episode of Better Call Saul and the first
episode of Breaking Bad, there are still a lot of
fascinating questions left to answer. Of course,
the biggest questions relate to the characters we
don't see during the original series; Kim, Nacho,
and Lalo. Other questions that tend to get thrown
around a lot are when will Jimmy fully become
Saul? And after season 5, are we going to see
Kim break bad? Are we gonna see Slippin' Kimmy?
I tend to think that both of these things already
happened. Honestly, I think the two "finger gun"
moments were the exclamation points on those
sentences. Jimmy officially started practicing
as Saul Goodman after being reinstated and his
strategy of leaning into being the kind of lawyer
guilty people hire is there. He isn't yet the
same person, it's a bit like a snowball rolling
downhill, what happens next will shape him,
that'll lead him to hone that persona to becoming
that person we first met, but the main difference
right now is that Kim is still the most important
thing in Jimmy's life. While Saul only appeared to
care about money and then maybe the thrill of what
he's able to get away with. Saying that Kim has
already broken bad might be an oversimplification
but she has made the decision to go after Howard
for what she thinks is a good reason. this is new
territory for her and this move might come with
consequences none of us are ready for. and I will
come back to both jimmy and Kim to refresh you
on where they're at at the beginning of season 6.
during the Breaking Bad series Saul Goodman is
the guy you go to in Albuquerque when you need a
criminal lawyer. emphasis on criminal. someone who
isn't above playing fast and loose with the rules.
this reputation led to him becoming the personal
lawyer of the infamous meth cook Walter White,
and that relationship led to him having to flee
and go into hiding at the end of that series.
better call saul opens in Omaha, Nebraska where
you see that this throwaway line to Walter White
about becoming a manager at a Cinnabon turned
out to come true. the new series starts out
there but it doesn't linger. you get exactly one
scene in Omaha at the beginning of each season
where you see that Saul has taken on the fake
identity of Gene Takavic. he's set up in a
normal if not boring life but it's clear that
he lives in constant fear of his true identity
being exposed that eventually happens in the
season 5 gene scene when he's approached by a
taxi driver from albuquerque and he calls ed to
disappear with the intention of running again
during their call he changes his mind and his
story is left with him saying that he'll handle
it himself what happens to gene aka saul aka
jimmy is arguably the biggest question there
is his ending is the end of the story probably the
very last thing that we'll see in this universe
people used to question about what kind of charges
he might be facing what was he really on the run
from or even if the authorities would still be
looking for him after five tenth seasons i don't
think there's any question that his paranoia
is well warranted he's not in a bubble he knows
what's going on in the outside world and his
identity being exposed is a huge deal you see
that he had the ability to run it felt like that
was probably the safest option but he chose to
go this different route to take action maybe go
into saw mode one last time the series opened
with gene and it will likely end there and i'm
hoping we'll get to spend a fair amount of time
seeing how that plays out nacho varga is another
character whose end is in question and is also on
the run at the end of season 5. nacho started
out as a pretty straightforward criminal type
who worked for the salamanca family you do end
up rooting for him by the end of the series but
it wasn't always that way over time he wants to
get out of the life but each attempt he makes
to try to get out backfires on him leaving him
more entrenched and generally worse off a lot
of why he becomes so sympathetic is because his
father who's a civilian gets caught up in things
and he tries to make that right initially hector
wanted to take over his upholstery business and
wanted to use it as a front for their smuggling
so that he wouldn't have to rely on gus that led
nacho to try to kill hector by swapping out his
heart medication with dummy capsules filled with
ibuprofen after the attempt was unsuccessful gus
figured out what he tried to do and he realized
that he could use that information to force him
to become a mole in the salamanca organization
nacho knows that if he doesn't do what he's told
his father will pay the ultimate price and he
hasn't been able to convince him that their only
option is to run by the end of season 5 lalo has
introduced him to don elattio as the salamanca's
guy in the north for at least the 10 remaining
months until tuko gets out of prison while he's in
mexico gus uses him to open up lalo's compound for
the mercenaries he's hired to kill him he does get
away but lolo now knows he was involved which is
a big problem since he's not dead his story will
pick up in season six with him trying to get out
of the country where he doesn't really have anyone
he can trust the salamancas and the cartel will be
after him and he's a liability to gus because
he could implicate him under questioning mike
has tried to talk gus into letting him get
out but so far that's fallen on deaf ears
he may be nacho's only hope in a situation
where it's in gus's interest to get him away
from the salamancas but where it would also make
sense to eliminate him once he's back in the u.s
what happens to lalo is also a big question nacho
and lalo are characters that were created from a
throwaway line from jimmy when walt and jesse were
trying to scare him into becoming badger's lawyer
when they took him out into the desert he says
it wasn't me it was ignacio referring to nacho
and then he's relieved when he finds out that it
wasn't lalo that sent them that would indicate
that saul thinks lalo is still alive or at the
very least he doesn't know what happened to him
that contradicts gus telling hector that everyone
in his family is dead and that the salamanca name
ends with him later in the series for what it's
worth gus seems like a more reliable source
lalo entered the story towards the end of
season 4 and has injected some life into the
cartel side of things he quickly became a worthy
adversary for gus causing him a lot of problems
his place in the salamanca family his
connection to the cartel made him untouchable
especially north of the border where gus would
be the prime suspect if anything happened to him
this led to the plan to have him arrested for
the money wire killing that involved an innocent
citizen then gus used jimmy to get him out of jail
so that he would be forced to jump bail and flee
back to mexico from there gus made his move at the
end of season 5 he sent that group of mercenaries
to take him out and they failed so lalo knows that
gus was behind that it should be clear that nacho
was involved but he also has the problem that
he's wanted in the united states of course it's
under a different name but it probably won't be
long before they realized that that was fake this
could mean that he might reach out to jimmy who is
now a friend of the cartel and what a journey he's
had to get to that point when we first met jimmy
mcgill the man that we'll eventually know as saul
goodman he was working as a public defender out
of the back of a nail salon driving around in
a suzuki esteem there was very little of the soul
we knew from breaking bad in this character in the
beginning he was far from successful but he did
take the idea of being a lawyer seriously he has
a checkered past he was a low-level scammer known
as slipping jimmy back in cicero illinois he gets
himself in some trouble but he also has a knack
for being able to talk his way out of difficult
situations his antics and a chicago sunroof in
particular got him in a situation where he was
in real trouble with the law he was about to go
to prison he had to reach out for the help of
his brother chuck who was a well-respected lawyer
to get him out of the situation and part of that
was him straightening up his life and moving to
albuquerque to take a job in the mailroom of one
of the most respected law firms in the city that's
also where he meets his girlfriend kim wexler
in the early going jimmy is mostly trying to
turn his life around he does still have that
tendency to cut corners but he works hard and
he's dedicated to taking care of his brother
who believes he has a condition that
makes him allergic to electricity
he does his best to leave the life of slipping
jimmy behind he gets his law degree and is hoping
to get hired on at hhm just like kim did but is
led to believe that howard hamlin doesn't want
him there the big reveal at the end of season one
after he pulls his stunt with the kettleman's to
show that he can do the right thing he learns that
it's been his brother chuck that's been holding
him back the whole time chuck doesn't believe he
can change he doesn't believe he's a real lawyer
and in his words jimmy with a law degree is like
a chimp with a machine gun the two brothers go
to war and eventually jimmy loses his license to
practice for a year chuck was trying to get him
permanently disbarred though and in their final
battle jimmy had to team up with kim to keep that
from happening they set up chuck to humiliate
himself in public in court in front of his peers
and he never really recovered from that he started
to turn things around for a period and jimmy did
come around and try to mend their relationship
only to be rejected by his brother one last time
in the end jimmy tipped off the insurance company
about chuck's outburst in court they threatened to
raise the malpractice rates for the entire firm
so howard asked chuck to consider retirement he
fought back that led to howard forcing him out and
his condition came back bringing him so low that
he decided to take his own life jimmy knows that
the stunt with the insurance company set off the
chain of events that led to chuck's suicide he
spent most of season 4 unable to deal with what
happened he was never able to process the loss of
his brother he also wasn't able to practice law so
he spent most of his time selling drop phones to
criminals and that turned out to be a successful
hustle he got the idea to practice law with the
same name that he was using with this clientele
since they were all the kind of people that would
eventually need a lawyer he officially became saul
goodman he primarily focused on these kinds
of clients and the days of him trying to be a
respectable lawyer to make his brother proud have
all but slipped away he'll throw himself into this
new practice and things will conspire so that he
won't have much time to reflect on how losing his
brother is affecting his life in the first half
of season 5 kim continues to focus on doing pro
bono work this serves as a way for her to get back
and she finds it more interesting and rewarding
than the banking law she does for mesa verde
she's called in to deal with a property owner
who refuses to leave his home even though mesa
verde is legally entitled to it mr acker has a
way of getting under her skin he lumps her in with
the rich people she works for he hits a nerve and
makes her question her motives and that leads to
her enlisting jimmy to represent him to go against
her own firm she works hard to give mesa birdie an
out one that would see mr acker stay in his house
but her client kevin wachtel won't back down
jimmy eventually encourages her to let it go but
she decides that she wants to take things to the
next level they plan to go after kevin personally
and force him to back down she eventually
changes her mind though when she realizes
that it's causing problems at her firm and she
tells jimmy to call off the plan he sees an
opportunity to pull it off without her and at the
same time make it look like he was doing this all
on his own from the beginning because they are a
couple there was suspicion that they were working
together in his mind this would actually be good
for kim and we see that she is visibly enraged by
his actions in the meeting so it is successful in
that sense but this also crosses a line for her
he made her the sucker and she doesn't see any
way forward for them other than to break up or
maybe they should just get married and that's what
they decide to do now this does establish spousal
privilege but they also have genuine feelings for
each other which come up when they exchange their
vows and throughout the rest of the season part of
this new arrangement is that jimmy has to tell her
things that he might not want to she wants to
know what he's up to what's going on with him
and we had seen that they drifted apart that they
were sort of living separate lives towards the end
of the third season and into the fourth as i've
already touched on jimmy does get involved with
lalo and becomes a friend of the cartel this will
bring up the first test of him being honest with
her he tells her the truth about going to pick
up lalo's bail from the cousins near the border
she thinks it's way too dangerous she's not okay
with it and more she doesn't understand why this
is so important to him he tells her she's worried
about nothing he goes through with it anyways
and of course things go wrong he does pick up
the money but he's ambushed by a gang of armed
criminals who are there to take it away from him
and he would have died right there if it weren't
for mike intervening and saving the day this
leads to a brutal trek through the desert after
the esteem finally craps out jimmy has to carry
the bag spilled with lalo's 7 million dollars in
cash and almost doesn't make it kim is completely
cut off from jimmy and terrified she even goes
to visit lalo in jail to see if she can learn
anything and then she just sort of has to sit
and wait nervously in their apartment until jimmy
finally gets a sell signal he goes to pay the bail
and lola is released and then he does come home
in the aftermath this bad decision only seems
to pull them closer together jimmy is wrecked
physically and he's suffering from ptsd and
kim just takes care of him overlooking the fact
that she knows he hasn't told her the whole story
things get intense when lalo decides to go
investigate things on his way back to mexico
he finds jimmy's car it has bullet holes in
it so he comes back to their apartment for
answers jimmy sticks to his story because mike
told him that he had to and lalo continues to
press him until kim steps up to take control
of the conversation she defends jimmy and turns
things back on lolo until he eventually leaves
the apartment to head back to mexico with nacho
jimmy does come clean about what really happened
in the desert and they decide to go and stay in a
hotel because they think that might be safer than
staying in their apartment kim has already quit
her job at schweikert and coakley so she heads to
the courthouse and picks up 20 new pro bono cases
jimmy is a basket case he's worried about lalo
and so he goes to talk to mike to find out why
he couldn't tell him the truth about what happened
mike lets him know that there's a plan in motion
where lalo will be killed once he gets back
to mexico and that's all he can tell him so
way back in the beginning when jimmy was doing
elder law he discovered that sandpiper crossing
was overcharging its residents and defrauding
them out of their money this led to a massive
class action suit by hhm and davis in maine
which will eventually provide jimmy with a
seven-figure payday this is something that takes
a long time though and at the end of season 5
kim comes up with this plan to try to force the
settlement early so that she can open up an office
and have a completely pro bono practice this
will require doing something terrible to howard
something that would generate enough negative
attention that it would make more sense for the
firms to take sam piper's offer and settle just to
make the story go away jimmy thinks this is going
too far and initially tries to talk her out of it
they have a history with howard and he's certainly
not jimmy's favorite person but he doesn't think
he deserves something like this after chuck's
death howard blamed himself and it almost broke
him during season 5 we saw that he turned things
around he bounced back he even tried to reach out
and hire jimmy at hhm this didn't have the desired
effect it actually set jimmy off to where he
was throwing bowling balls at his car and paying
hookers to show up at fork to embarrass him he
overlooked this at first thinking that jimmy was
just going through something until it all came to
a head when he blew up on him at the courthouse
and then a little bit later he thought he needed
to warn kim about it when she told him she quit
her job he was coming from a place of saying that
jimmy needed help which to his credit is true
but he came at kim in the worst way and totally
turned her against him in the process he told her
what was going on in a way that assumed that she
couldn't see that jimmy was having problems and
since in his mind no one would make the decision
to leave her job he insisted that jimmy must have
influenced her decision in some way she ended up
unloading on him saying do you have any idea how
insulting that is i make my own decisions for my
own reasons he throws more fuel on the fire saying
you know who really knew jimmy chuck and she
decides that it wouldn't be a big deal to go after
him picking up where jimmy had already started
she assures her husband that she's prepared to go
through with it and while he doesn't look nearly
as certain you can imagine that he'll get on board
with whatever it is she wants to do when this
series started it almost functioned as two shows
in one you have what was going on with jimmy
and then you had mike's story that went off in
its own direction as we near the end things have
been drawn together with the introduction of lalo
mike's story is somewhat overshadowed by that and
what's happening with nacho we know how things
end for mike and at this point we can see how he
got on the slippery slope of being one of gus's
most trusted guys he took the job helping with the
super lab thinking that there was a low chance of
any violence being involved and ended up having to
kill someone he had become friends with in verner
that put him on a self-destructive path in the
beginning of season 5 until gus intervened and
sent him off to mexico there he explained to him
that he needed a soldier and i'm not sure if he
made enough of a case to have mike set aside his
personal code the thing that had kept him from
going all in on working with him in the first
place but it certainly opened up the path in
season 5 it felt like mike made a decision to play
the hand he was dealt in other words do what he's
good at in service of providing for kaylee after
he's gone which is pretty rough when you think
about how it all plays out now that gus has failed
to take out lalo it seems like their showdown will
take over most of the action on that side of the
story and i think i should leave things there i'm
super excited to find out what happens with gene
why kim doesn't appear to be around anymore during
the breaking bad timeline how this whole thing
plays out with howard whether or not nacho and
his dad make it out and then what happens to lalo
so let me know in the comments what you're most
interested in what you're thinking about let
me know if you have any questions about what
happened in the series so far tell me how you
think it might end and what you most want to see
happen in this final season we're coming
to the end of the breaking bad universe
and i can't wait to see how it all ends please
like this video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already i'll be
doing episode recaps and weekly bonus videos
all throughout this season so make sure you come
back and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon